first in a pan heat olive oil add  chopped onion and fry until soft then  finely sliced garlic and chili  at cumin  cinnamon and black beans then combined  cook together until it's deliciously  soft these small beings come dried or in  tins and there are great cheap  ingredient to make dishes more  substantial to serve dollop the black  bean mixture on crunchy tortillas top  with cube ripe avocado chopped fresh  coriander and crumbled salty feta cheese  spicy black beans with feta and avocado  a dish that's filling Google and tastes  fantastic  start to take on a completely different  texture nice crisp sauteed texture on  the outside then slide onto a plate flip  over and return to the pan to finish  cooking